[MUSIC]
In 1987, President Ronald Reagan
famously demanded Gorbachev,
the President of the Soviet Union,
to tear down that wall.
His speech laid the foundation for
this moment for two years later.
Thousands of East Germans
camped outside the German
embassy in Hungary demanding
access across the border, and
three fundamental things,
freedom, safety and reunification.
Now, I wasn't born yet.
Because of that moment, when I grew up
in Berlin, there were no more walls,
and another even questioned the right to
safety and freedom, until this happens.
Four years ago, thousands of people were
stranded at the Hungarian border yet
again, but this time it wasn't
German citizens who pleaded for
the world to pay attention,
it was Syrian refugees.
This sparked a movement across my country.
Images like this,
of people welcoming refugees into Germany,
went around the world.
I was so proud, so I decided to
leave my corporate job in the UK and
move back to Berlin to support
my government in absorbing
the 1 million refugees
that ended up arriving.
That moment changed my life, since then
I've met some incredible refugees.
And Wright was some of the most dedicated
people I know who try to support them.
Their strengths and resilience has become
my source of inspiration and drive.
But at the same time,
the public conversation has changed.
The outpouring of support has
turned into protest and fear.
Instead of tearing down walls,
we are building them.
This scares me, I don't fear that we
have lost control of our boarders,
I fear that we have lost control
of our fundamental values.
What has happened?
Let’s atart with the basics.
There are 68 million
refugees in the world today.
These are people that have been
forced to flee from their homes
because of conflict and violence.
Take Syria,
a country that has become synonymous
with the world's refugee crisis.
The Syrian war started nine
years ago with the Arab Spring.
After a 13-year-old boy was tortured and
murdered for
writing a pro-Arab Spring graffiti,
people went out on the streets to protest,
peacefully.
But President Bashar Al Assad
responded with gunfire.
It sparked one of the deadliest
civil wars in our modern times,
leaving 500,000 people dead, and
12 million forcefully displaced.
That is two-thirds of the entire country.
These are people who stood
up to demand freedom,
safety, and democracy.
They fight for the values we preach.
And we ignored them until they
literally showed up at our borders.
At the height of the crisis,
sometimes thousands of refugees came
into just Berlin in a given week.
On one of my first days working for
the government there,
I went to visit an old decommissioned
airport at the heart of the city.
The local state office had resorted
to seizing whatever they could
find as shelters,
because there simply wasn't any space.
That included school gyms and
the old airport's foyer.
But what I found was this.
1,000 bunk beds cramped into what
look like an industrial hall.
2,000 people lived here,
people from different cultures,
different families,
from all over the worlds.
The echo made the noise
level almost unbearable.
There is no peace and quiet, no privacy.
Some of the people who came looking for
freedom and
safety had to stay here for
almost two years.
They were safe, yes, but free?
Not really.
I remember a social worker who came and
pleaded with us to help
a refugee who was severely disabled and
suffered from PTSD.
Placing him here was cruel, not just for
him, but really for everyone.
Imagine trying to sleep whilst he
was enjoying his night terrors.
He needed individual care, but
we simply weren't able to provide it.
If there's one thing I learned that day,
it is that no one chooses this life,
you're placed in it if
you're out of options.
And there's something else I learned.
If you're facing this humanitarian crisis,
it forces you to make tradeoffs.
Who gets prioritized for
individual care, and who doesn't?
Who gets to stay, and who doesn't?
All of these decisions have
a tremendous human cost,
and not just to the refugees,
but really to all of us.
Accommodating refugees
requires a sacrifice.
And some of it might be small,
like getting used to sharing your public
spaces with people who look
really different to you.
Or giving up your school gym for
two years.
And some as big,
like having government resources
diverted away from your local projects.
It really is no wonder that
the cycle of history always follows
the same pattern when it
comes to refugee movements.
In 1938, 67% of Americans were opposed
to granting refuge to Jewish
people fleeing Nazi persecution.
My own grandma came to
Germany as a refugee.
She was German, but
she grew up in the Sudetenland,
a small strip between Czechoslovakia and
Germany.
After World War II,
all the Germans living there had
a day to pack their bags and leave.
Even though she shared a nationality and
a language with the people
in her new hometown,
she was not greeted with kindness.
My point is, this is a vicious cycle of
history every generation perpetuates.
And this crisis really is no different.
If we judge previous generations on
whether or not they took a stance,
will future generations
not do the same to us?
I worry because I know that
the sacrifice is painful.
While I was working in government
I organized a town hall meeting in
one of the most liberal
districts of Berlin,
where you can find welcome refugee
posters on every street corner.
We had to ask the residents to
give up a tiny piece of their
large neighborhood park for
a new refugee shelter.
It turns out the people were furious.
I know that we can't take everyone in.
But that is not what
we're debating right now,
instead we're turning a blind eye again.
We're coming out with all
the creative arguments for
why we don't have the resources to help.
We are we not the best place to help?
Why, in fact,
isolation is the best answer?
We are back at the vicious
cycle of history.
I know that we can break it.
But for that,
I'm asking you to make a sacrifice.
To stand up for
the values I know we all share.
And that might not be today.
I'm asking you to remember this talk when
the time comes for you to make a choice.
Do I truly open my arms,
even if it costs me, or do I look away?
And that cost might be small,
like speaking out publicly,
even if it's risky, or giving up a tiny
space in your neighborhood park.
Or it might be big,
like going out of your way to create
opportunities for
refugees in your future companies.
Every decision, every action counts.
Previous generations might have
not gotten it all right, but
our countries share history in
literally tearing down walls together.
I don't want to be the generation
that builds them back up.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]